c'est dans cette usine rivière des
prairies qu'on apporte la grande
majorité des morceaux de viande rejetée
par les abattoirs pour les transformer
une activité qui est loin de passer
inaperçue c'est comme l'eau des deux
cadavres mais pas très fermé mes
fenêtres aussi parce que sinon lauder
lente à l'intérieur de la maison on
était là
s'appuient beaucoup la communauté
métropolitaine de montréal veut régler
le problème avec un nouveau règlement
sur la pollution atmosphérique qui
encadre les concentrations d'odeur il
doit être approuvé par québec avant
d'entrer en vigueur mais sanimax vous
convaincre le gouvernement le goût d'en
retarder l'adoption sa survie en dépend
firme d'entreprise qui s'est d'abord
confié au quotidien le devoir nous
pouvons vous confirmer qu appliquer
telle quelle et de façon stricte le
règlement est bel et bien pour impact
direct de révoquer nous permis ce qui
mettrait fin à nos opérations à montréal
je ne pense pas que
ça va me fait de la peine c'est s'anima
c'est parti une perspective qui cause de
l'inquiétude dans l'industrie
agroalimentaire qui envoie ses sous
produits de porc et de poulet chez
sanimax pour qu'il soit transformé si
l'usiné devait fermer mais ça aurait
comme impact qu'on aurait qu'on devrait
rediriger la cette matière lire sites
d'enfouissement le nouveau règlement
interdire l entreposage de matières
animales à ciel ouvert et obligerait
sanimax à construire un garage pour
accueillir les camions qui viennent
décharger leurs marchandises afin
d'éviter la propagation des odeurs dans
le voisinage
l'entreprise se dit ouverte à construire
un garage et a d'ailleurs pris un
engagement similaire dans ses
installations de lévis mais estime qu'un
délai de 18 mois est trop court pour y
parvenir au cabinet de la mairesse
plante on déplore que des discussions
qui se sont échelonnés sur deux ans et
qui ont pris fin d'été dernier n'est pas
permis à la ville et sanimax de
s'entendre en aucun cas la ville n'a eu
entre les mains un plan complet incluant
des solutions et technologies permettant
d'atteindre les normes en termes de
qualité de l'air et de l'eau
indique-t-on le gouvernement ne goana
lisent toujours le règlement de la
communauté métropolitaine de montréal
entre temps tant la ville que sanimax se
disent prêts à relancer les pourparlers
conjointement avec québec pour dénouer
l'impasse il se lie vielles bachar radio
canada montréal